[Music]
thank you for joining us
the night sky over israel and gaza has
been lit up by
a series of rocket attacks and bombings
as violence continues between israel and
the palestinians
the u.n security council is set to
discuss the conflict later
after days of bomb attacks as well as
protests and clashes on the ground in
israel and the occupied west bank
around midnight local time hamas fired a
barrage of rockets from gaza
towards tel aviv air raid sirens went
off
as the rockets flew over the city and
were intercepted by the iron dome
system around 10 people were injured
while running for bomb shelters
according to local medics
israel has reported that at least nine
people have died
including two children since monday
israel's military launched a wave of
airstrikes on
several locations in gaza including the
home of hamas's chief there
palestinian officials say at least four
people were killed and
more were injured according to the
palestinian authority
at least 149 people have died since the
conflict began on monday
in an effort to ease tensions u.s
president joe biden has spoken to the
israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu and the palestinian
president mahmoud abbas
in separate phone calls he called for a
de-escalation from both sides and for
peace in the region
after the phone call israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu held a news
conference
and blamed hamas for the upsurge in
violence
this past week millions of israelis were
forced into bomb shelters
as missiles rained down on our cities
several israelis have been killed many
more have been wounded
you know and i know no country would
tolerate this
israel
meanwhile hamas chief ismael haniyeh has
warned that
palestinians in gaza will not retreat in
the face of attacks
by israel speaking to a crowd of
supporters in qatar he said palestinians
will not accept anything less
than a palestinian state with jerusalem
as
its capital now foreign affairs editor
deborah haines joins me now from
jerusalem and deborah is there any sense
that the
international efforts at brokering peace
are making any inroads at all
well certainly not and quite the
opposite in fact there's been a further
escalation in the early hours of this
morning with the israeli military saying
that they targeted the top
hamas leader in in gaza his house he's
not believed to
have been there at the time but a
signifi a significant step by them and
also
a signal that they are not letting up
despite
mounting concern about the heavy toll
this crisis is having on civilians
you've talked about how
nine israelis have died in in the last
week
um on the palestinian side in gaza um
palestinian health officials saying more
than 140
people have been killed the israeli
military say that at least
more than 30 of them were hamas
militants
but the palestinians say at least 40
children
have been killed and there's also
significant condemnation
concern about the fact that the israeli
defense forces decided to target
a multi-story building in gaza city that
housed a number of
news organizations the israelis say they
did this because hamas was also using
that location
but the ap news agency and al jazeera
have expressed concern about the ability
of the press to go about doing their job
documenting
what's happening in gaza on both sides
the rockets being launched from gaza
towards israel and then the impact of
the israeli airstrikes
into gaza you talked about the
diplomatic effort
clearly urgent diplomacy is underway the
united states sent
a special envoy to this region he
arrived in israel
on friday talking to the israelis
talking
to the palestinian authority the u.s
does not have direct links
with hamas and that's why regional
players like egypt like
qatar interesting that the hamas leader
himself was in qatar
at the moment or at least he was last
night when he made those comments
they are all involved trying to bring uh
cool heads trying to just
stop the fighting no one thinks they can
strike a peace deal but at the moment
the absolute focus is on trying
to stop the the bombardments and the
counter bombardments
later today the u.n security council
will be holding their first
public session they've held a number of
closed
sessions since this crisis started last
week but this is the first time we'll be
hearing from the security council
in open session deborah thanks very much
for that update
also this morning it's the evolve the
next stage of unlocking the coveted 19
lockdown but boris johnson is facing
pressure as to whether it's safe to
continue easing regulations in england
with some scientists warning that
relaxing measures could lead to a new
peak of infections from the indian
variant let's look at some of the
changes coming into force from
tomorrow in england a maximum six people
or two households will be able to meet
indoors
groups of up to 30 will be able to meet
outdoors
indoor service for pubs and restaurants
will begin again
and other venues such as cinemas museums
and theaters will be allowed to reopen
with some restrictions it's a similar
picture in wales
indoor hospitality will open from
tomorrow indoor leisure such as cinemas
and museums will also open their doors
again
and like england and scotland
international travel from wales will be
permitted with all
three countries sharing the traffic
light system
most of mainland scotland will enter
level two from monday
except glasgow and moray which remain in
level three
in level two six people from three
households can meet indoors and stay
overnight
up to 50 people are allowed to attend
weddings and funerals
and restaurants and pubs can now serve
alcohol indoors
milana reports as the country prepares
for its next step
towards normality on the brink of
further reopening a worrying new version
of the virus is taking hold
cases of the indian variant have more
than doubled in the past week
but the government says it will press on
with tomorrow's planned unlocking
when indoor dining will resume it does
come with a warning from the pm
that people need to judge the risk for
themselves
the difficulty here is that in terms of
human behavior we take a lot of cues
from the authorities by
continuing on with alleviating the
lockdown
the onus is on the public to
[Music]
engage in you know particular type of
behavior make their best decisions
but the signal very much is one of
um of relaxation and and that's a
problem
scientists are concerned that the indian
variant could be more transmissible at a
time when many still await their jabs
and that the message about being
cautious could be lost among further
lock down lifting if they've allowed it
it makes you think that
obviously it's safe yeah you wouldn't
think differently
because that's who you trust at the end
of the day the government
i feel fine like i feel really
comfortable to be honest
um i don't really got any worries i
think hopefully kyle is staying down
anyway now
like definitely more comfortable you
know we're just going by
what the updates are so yeah even on a
rainy night like this people are clearly
relishing being out and about again and
from monday
with the freedom to dine indoors
restaurants like this one
will be even busier but the government
is worried about the indian variant and
with the risk of transmission greater
indoors the question is if this latest
step in reopening
is here to stay authorities have
emphasized the need for responsible
behavior
but in glasgow on saturday police broke
up a large gathering of rangers fans
celebrating an unbeaten season events
like these could make a more
transmissible variant
harder to control and the pm has warned
that further spread could delay the
final stage of lockdown easing in june
but he's faced heat for that from senior
backbenchers like steve baker
who says the vaccines continue to work
writing in the sunday telegraph mr baker
accuses the government of a campaign of
fear
saying it would of course be irrational
to impose restrictions when this is what
the data tell us
we were told the roadmap was cautious
precisely so it would be irreversible
but the virus doesn't stick to
timetables and the prime minister knows
that he has a tough
balancing act on his hands milena
vasilinovic
sky news
health secretary matt hancock will be on
safe ridge on sunday to discuss the
government's response to the indian
variant that's at half past eight
let's take a look now at the latest
coronavirus figures for the uk
they've been at 2027 new cases reported
in the latest 24-hour period
seven more deaths were also reported
which means the total number of people
who've died within
28 days of a positive test now stands at
127
675 another
204 912 people have received their first
vaccination and 379 111 people got their
second
in total 56 million jabs have now been
administered
across the uk the nhs says there's been
a surge of vaccine bookings amongst
people aged 38 and 39.
more than six hundred thousand have
booked for a cover jab within
48 hours of appointments being opened up
over 35s are likely to be called up
in the coming days a major incident has
been declared after a suspected gas
explosion
at a residential area in haitian
lancashire
firefighters were called to a row of
terrorist houses on
maladail avenue in the early hours of
this morning and are searching a
collapsed
property lancashire police say they're
at the scene
and nearby homes have been evacuated
a number of residents have reported that
as many as
three houses may have collapsed it's
currently unclear
if anyone has been injured
the artificial voice of the late
physicist stephen hawking
is familiar around the world but
pioneering software can now allow
patients to bank their
own voice if they're in danger of losing
it to disease
motor neurone disease charities say it's
significantly improved the quality of
life for patients
and are calling for it to be offered on
the nhs gerard tub has the details
icelander friedrich thorstenson founded
his
seafood processing firm in grimsby 20
years ago
but now he has multiple system atrophy
msa a progressive neurological disorder
that is rapidly robbing him of his voice
in the quiet of his office he explained
how important it is to him
to preserve how he used to sound using
technology called
voice banking the thing is that your
voice
and with my voice isn't part of my
identity
so of course this is very important for
me to be able to keep my voice
i have motor neurone disease a
progressive condition that reduces my
powers of movement perhaps the most
famous synthesized voice was that of
physicist stephen hawking
but that robotic sound is no longer
necessary
frederick has recorded a few hundred
words and phrases
into software that allows him to type
into his phone
and speak as he used to i managed to get
together people from the parkinson's
organization and mnd license i am
starting a charity fund called my voice
where mr patients can have help funding
voice banking as well as having access
to a computer to talk through once they
lose their voice
a promotional video has been released by
dorset
nhs trust showing how the system works
the trust has been a pioneer in voice
banking
and has now made it a permanent part of
its service for patients who will lose
their voice
when you're given a diagnosis like that
there's very little the consultants can
say to you that you can actively do to
manage your condition
so having something like voice banking
which is actually something really
positive that you can focus your time on
to
you can you can your thoughts can be
sort of controlled onto doing something
that is proactive means a lot to
patients
the dorset service works with the motor
neuron disease association
which wants to see voice banking made
more widely available
last year we funded about 250 people to
bank their voices
and it's the demand is going up as the
iran awareness raises
um and each time somebody banks their
voice that costs money to the
association so that's people running
marathons to
to raise that money so i would like to
hope in the future that is funded
through the nhs
meanwhile friedrich is putting 20 000
pounds
into his new charity to help others
capture their voice before it's too late
gerard tub sky news grimsby
[Music]
let's return to our top story and
there's been another night of violence
between israel and the palestinians with
the u.n security council
set to discuss the conflict later
joining me now to discuss this more is
jose verricat senior advisor
at the european institute of peace good
morning to you
and this is the seventh day of the
conflict now with escalations overnight
are we looking at full-blown war now
i think so i think this is definitely
the fourth war
uh since the first war in 2008 2009
um you know we've already reached an
enormous number of
killed and wounded in gaza in particular
and
the violence is no holds barred from
from both sides particularly on the side
of israel and the incomparable
damage being caused in in gaza to
infrastructure
and to humans
we've seen president biden speaking to
the israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu and
the president the palestinian president
mahmoud abbas
um this has happened overnight do you
think that this possibly might be
a turning point in the international
community having some sway
as to whether there will be a ceasefire
um i mean i think it's important of
course i think engagement from the u.s
administration is
essential um i don't think there is
anything particularly new
unfortunately um particularly
obviously it's um it's it's blatant that
the youth administration has no contacts
with hamas
um speaking to mahmoud their bands will
have and only a
very limited impact real mediation will
be taking place between
israel and hamas or you know indirectly
whether through the u.n the unenvoy or
through egypt or
through other parties i think sending an
envoy
obviously censored signal but we haven't
heard
anything that we hadn't heard before
about the
the conflict in gaza and i think new
ideas really need to be
introduced into the discussion very
important for it to be discussed at the
security council
for other parties also to express their
opinion
i think that you know we've seen four
wars
since 2008 11009 um
and it's just it's clearly that the
underlying course is not being addressed
these are stock-out measures that are
being introduced
these are only short-term solutions that
are being offered and um
we're probably going to see exactly the
same this time around
it will probably end in cairo with some
sort of
ceasefire that will not really address
um you know the fundamental problems
which is the
the siege of gaza two million people
under siege for the past 15 years
and the overarching conflict in the west
bank as well
between palestinians and israelis the
fundamental political courses this is
not
just a conflict about security
about um self-defense this is
you know about real nationalist demands
from
um from palestinians um about
sovereignty
about basic rights that are being
violated so i think uh particularly in
relation to gaza
we need uh we need a political solution
um
israel has only offered very short-term
solutions to gaza it has only offered
marginal relief of the siege
and you can't continue having two
million people um
under siege completely and they're
blockade unable to move
practically you know the majority
population in gaza today has never left
the gaza strip
so what we need are more global
solutions we also need palestinian
elections
you know this has been something that
indirectly
has blocked progress on a broader
political solution and has impacted
violence right now
clearly it's a classic case book study
of
uh political fragmentation of the loss
of a political
closure of a political horizon turning
to violence
hamas um could have engaged in a
political process
through those elections um and
and and you know channeled their
ambitions and their aspirations and
palestinian ambitions and aspirations
through politics and i wanted to sorry
to interrupt
we're running out of time i just wanted
to ask you whether you think there's
something more
uh worrying about this particular bout
of conflict because for the first time
or many people are saying it's the first
time
we're seeing conflicts between israeli
jews and israeli arabs
in mixed neighborhoods playing out on
the streets
yeah absolutely clearly this has been uh
it has taken on new new dimensions from
the beginning
attacking responding to
an escalation in jerusalem to
aggressions
against the alexander mosque or the
temple mount
and also the response of population
in israel of palestinian israeli
population
in israel the solidarity and hamas has
really been very opportunistic
and has exploited at the moment the kind
of
the status quo blockade politically
and has gathered enormous momentum and
um and
of course you know this is an
unprecedented escalation
jose very cat senior advisor at the
european institute of peace uh thank you
very much for sharing your analysis with
us
thank you let's take a look at the
weather now with
nas what have you got more of the same
no big changes in the weather i'm afraid
not for today and not for
the new week either we're going to
continue with a cool and showery
unsettled theme
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so no big changes with a
weather forecast i'm afraid we are going
to continue with the cool and showery
theme for today
and into the new week as well in fact it
does look like it's going to be quite a
wet and windy day as we get towards a
thursday for many places until then it's
a case of showers and they will be heavy
and thundery currently
across parts of northern england where
it's a cloudy start to the day as well
and across parts of wales and southern
areas of england we are seeing some
heavy showers elsewhere it's mostly fine
and dry
quite chilly across some rural spots of
scotland where we've had clear spells
overnight some patches of mist and fog
there
into this afternoon the showers do
become more widespread
just like previous days and they will be
quite heavy and thundery in places
there's even going to be the risk of
hail again
and they will be quite prolonged across
wales and
central parts of england in particular
as they will be quite slow moving across
these parts winds are stronger
across southern areas of england so that
will move through the showers quite
quickly so they'll be
a bit more short-lived there it's
generally looking quite cool for the
time of year temperatures around
average or a little below i think the
highest temperatures today will be
across parts of the northeast of england
this is sky news breakfast coming up
we'll be looking at what impact the
indian variant may have on britain's
unlocking
ahead of tomorrow's lifting of
restrictions
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast a
major incident has been declared after a
suspected gas explosion
in a residential area in haitian
lancashire
firefighters were called to a row of
terrorist houses on maladail avenue in
the early hours of this morning
and are searching a collapsed property
sally chowdhury joins us on the phone
now from the site
of the incident and talia what more can
you tell us
uh well jillian a major incident has
been declared here and
on the street there are police fire and
rescue
trucks lining up
there's a cordon in place um there are
also
engineers from the local gas supplier
who are here this was as we know a gas
explosion the neighbors
around here who are actually all on
their front lawns uh
trying to figure out what has happened
have described hearing a loud
blast some of them described it like a
bomb going off
um in the early hours of the morning
they all
obviously they said they rushed out to
see what had happened
now uh as you say there's a row of
terrorist houses or maybe they
they were semi-detached houses which
there's like a gap in
in in the horizon now where those houses
were and just some of the chimney stacks
are still standing
um other than that you know the place
seems completely empty but there is
accordance so we can't get any closer
but i managed to get into the back
garden of one of the neighboring
properties um and there are roof tiles
all over the floor there's so much
damage to this
gentleman's back garden and he said it's
all from you know
he said it felt like vertical uh you
know
roof tiles just falling vertically onto
onto his garden
um and many of them say that they were
they were approached by emergency
services and told
to turn off their gas supplies and uh
one lady said to me
she was asked not to turn on her car
engine for the first
hour or so after the explosion um
there's a lot of confusion here from
from the neighbors they want to know
what happened and whether it is safe to
go inside
one lady was saying her her next-door
neighbor took a long time to go back
into her house
because she was that afraid but
investigations are continuing
and we should know a bit more later on
in the day
i will be back to you for that thank you
the government is pushing ahead with
tomorrow's easing of lockdown despite
warnings from
senior scientists that loosening
restrictions could cause a surge of the
indian variant of the covid virus
let's speak now to dr julian tang
honorary associate professor
at the respiratory sciences department
of the university of leicester good
morning to you and
with cases of the indian variant almost
three times the number that we saw
last week are you comfortable with the
loosening of covered restrictions come
tomorrow
um morning it doesn't mean we're
comfortable
um i think the vaccinations will prevent
severe disease and death but they're
still
you know 20 to 30 million uh in the 40s
and some over 50
and over 40 still get vaccinated
uh this virus may well be more
transmissible
if you're not immune it may infect and
spread amongst the non-immune
you may get clusters of cases in certain
areas
a few of which may need hospitalization
because we know from the kent variant
from last year's experience that
if you have enough cases you'll always
find some that actually get more
severely ill
and although this younger population
should be less prone to that
the variant is thought though to be more
than 50 percent
more transmissible than what we've seen
with the kent variant isn't it
well there's some debate around this uh
i know there's a a
article in the times yesterday
suggesting could be a founder effect
but this was the same the debate we had
as last as last year with the kent
variant
and that did turn out to be more
transmissible and evolutionary wise
you know the virus is more likely to be
more transmissible that might cause more
severe disease because it doesn't want
to
kill its host because it's negative for
the virus either
do we know categorically whether
the vaccine is sufficient to combat
the indian variant uh we don't know
categorically because
there's no real data lab or otherwise
yet
looking at this in a very kind of robust
manner
um but the lack of the 484 mutation for
it for
q for the indian variants and 44k for
other variants like south african
brazilian
suggests that it may be less vaccine
resistant
however it does share the 452r mutation
that we see in the californian
u.s variant that does seem to confer
some
reduced vaccine efficacy and also some
enhanced transmissibility
and what's your view on on variants
because that there
have been others in the past there there
will be other variants in the future i
mean should we stop being scared of
every
single new variant because a lot of
people will have antibodies
the vaccination program means that a lot
of people at least have the first
vaccine um
do we need to stop being so fearful of
new
variants yeah so i think you know as
with other viruses as you
as we are exposed more and more over
time to different circulating variants
uh and with different vaccines being
updated seasonally
and you build up a library of immune
responses both being t cell
antibodies and cell mediated that will
then help you to reduce
severe disease and death from these
variants and it may just reduce down to
a common cold you know
years from now but at the moment i think
the first
exposure to a pandemic virus that may
have unpredictable effects
if we don't predict those who are
vulnerable and we have seen that over
the past
14 months or so would you advise against
lifting all
restrictions on june the 21st uh
i think it's too early to say that yeah
let's see how it goes uh from tomorrow
and forwards
uh i will know in a couple of weeks how
this this new variant's gonna search
if if it does surge through the uk
population
um in the presence of the ongoing
vaccine program
[Music]
dr julian tang thank you for sharing
your expertise with us this morning
thank you
let's take a look at the weather now for
you with nurse
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning no big changes in the
weather forecast i'm afraid for today
it's another cool and showery picture
and it remains unsettled and cool for
the time of year into the new week as
well quite wet and windy conditions
expected on thursday in fact until then
it's a case of showers and currently
those showery outbreaks rain across
parts of northern northeastern parts of
england wales and
southern counties of england as well
elsewhere it's a mainly dry and bright
start but
not for long as we go into this
afternoon showers will become more
widespread
and much like previous days they're
likely to be heavy and thundering places
there's also going to be the risk of
hail like the previous days as well and
some of them are going to be quite slow
moving so some rather prolonged
downpours mainly across parts of wales
and
central england where the winds will be
lighter but the winds are going to be
quite brisk along the south coast today
down towards the southwest and even some
eastern areas
so that will move along those showers a
bit quicker so they're not going to be
as prolonged they're more short-lived
showers for scotland
faring best with the driest conditions
the lighter showers there
and less frequent but still there will
be some showers scattered across there
as well and generally it will be a cool
day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's 7 42 still to come on sky news
breakfast we're going to be taking a
look at the newspapers with the comedian
mark dolan
and the entrepreneur kate hardcastle
[Music]
with us now to take us through the
newspapers comedian mark dolan and the
entrepreneur
kate hardcastle welcome back to both of
you and starting with you mark first of
all and this story
in the sun about labor being behind
in the polls some 13 points i believe
that's right what had looked like
something of a blip now resembles
long-term
decline in support for the labour party
it's like a football club that's
struggling and keeps changing
its manager but the results are just not
coming in and
the fact that we're at the tail end of
the biggest recession in 300 years
a perception certainly in some quarters
that the government have handled
the pandemic badly a debate about
whether the prime minister
locked down too late in the first place
you know it should be
rich pickings for an opposition party
but we saw what happened
two weeks ago super thursday a drubbing
um something that never happens jillian
which is for a sitting government
to win a by-election i mean as a
political nerd that's unheard of
especially to take a seat
from labour and in hartlepool that's of
course been in their possession for
decades
so what's going wrong what's the problem
well i've spoken to labour figures
who focus on the vaccine bounced and of
course the vaccine rollout has
rolled out has been a great success for
this government and it will have one of
them flawed it but i think there's a
wider story and it's the fact that
labour support is
split now between metropolitan remain
voters
who are socially liberal and patriotic
pro-brexit voters in those red wall
seats in the north of england two
different parties two different
constituencies and we've seen kierstarma
try to ride
two horses it's not possible and we're
seeing the consequences
i think kiyostama is going to have to
pick a side you know labour's great
dilemma now
is not who their leader is because
anybody the most charismatic figure in
politics
couldn't solve labour's issue and the
issue is does it turn left
and head back to carbonism or does it
turn right and head back to blarism
and that's the great dilemma facing not
just kierstarma but the wider party
movement
let us uh move away from politics for
the moment and have a look at business
uh in the mirror
kate uh the closing of debenhams and
this is after me two and a half
centuries on the high street
it really was quite a landmark day
yesterday we knew it was coming we know
that the boohoo group have purchased the
debenhams brand and it's now
online only and it's quite clear and
evident that the future
for that is going to be combining all of
the brands they own and putting them
under that site
so it's not going to feel like the same
debenhams as you remembered in the
department stores
it's it's certainly from a business
perspective quite easy to look at the
debenhams
legacy see what they did brilliantly but
also see where the feelings came
really placing the trips on the fact
that retail
for them was going to carry on in the
same vein in the same way with online
just being a small part of it
but obviously yesterday was also about
trying to remember all the staff workers
and i think
quite poignant day for our high streets
we've talked about them for years we
know that they've been in need of
evolution we know they need to be more
human
we know we need more social interaction
and places to be particularly as we all
rejoin
together after a year of really not
seeing each other
but they can't just hang their hat on
retail and i think what we're going to
see before we see
the next catalyst for that change and
actually start to see some of these
high streets of the future it's going to
be quite a sad picture actually in a lot
of bigger cities particularly
because we know as well as losing
debenhams and the arcadia group brands
like topshop
dorothy perkins we're also going to see
the store closures from
programmes that john lewis and mark and
spencer's have both been running over
recent months
to try and really tighten up on their
start network and try and
save costs moving a lot of their
investment online so
i think we're going to go through some
real high street pain over the next
couple of years before
we see what can be our future there it's
not dead it's evolving but it's
certainly going to be quite sad and
yesterday a really poignant day
yeah no indeed are we interested to see
how the high street changes and evolves
as you say
uh back to politics and scottish
independence mark this is a piece
from uh gavin essler the writer and
broadcaster
that's right the headline is a pretty
explosive one jillian
wake up england scottish independence
will have seismic
implications for everyone not just in
scotland but south of the border
and i do think that's why scottish
independence needs to be a national
conversation it
affects all four nations of the country
because there will be
implications for the gdp of the rest of
the uk
if scotland leave and gavin essler's
point which is
really interesting is that nicolas
sturgeon has been allowed to dominate
the debate now of course she has a you
know a huge mandate
she of course last thursday achieved not
quite a majority
in hollywood but another mandate to
pursue
and press on with independence the
question is whether boris johnson will
grant that now the idea of a
westminster-based
prime minister granting or not granting
a public vote in scotland the optics of
that are not great and that will
you know embolden the nationalists we've
got to be granted democracy
by someone in london but the truth is
that it is a british conversation
and english welsh and northern irish
people will also be
you know impacted and yeah i just think
that you need to hear all voices the
reason why
there is such a vacuum is because nicola
sturgeon is one of the most effective
politicians
in the country she's an articulate she
is very clear with her messaging and
she has managed to sort of leverage
support uh
in scotland for her project quite often
from voters who don't even want
independence
it's not 100 of snp voters
that actually want independence but she
is considered
a steady hand at the tiller but you know
the the counterbalance has to be
questions like would we have had an
extraordinary success with the vaccine
rollout if it wasn't for the uk
for example what would the currency be
of an independent scotland
would an independent scotland be able to
borrow as cheaply on the international
bond markets
as the uk has been able to do during
this pandemic
um questions to which there may be
satisfactory
answers from the smp but not questions
that are currently being posed
no lots of questions to be answered as
you suggest there to
the observer okay completely different
story um
the um rise of the croc
do you own a pair yes i do
and victoria beckham said she wouldn't
be seen dead wearing one and it is the
marmite of footwear
so if that makes us on opposite sides of
the love and hate of this
piece of footwear that i quite celebrate
then there we go
i mean it's really interesting from a
business story because this gives a
little bit of hope for brands out there
i think
in 2009 the organization was very near
bankruptcy
but with some magic marketing some brand
affiliation with
very big celebrities and the first ever
gold pair won on the oscars catwalk
last week i think they've really turned
it around i mean what's not to love
jillian don't you have some
um i did have but i didn't wear them
outside of the house oh look
mark's showing us his those are slides
those aren't crocs those are sliders
that's different i want to apologize i
want to apologize to the croc
organization which is obviously an
excellent company but i found a
you know slightly more budget version uh
and
they always seem to be the worst
possible color don't they
and uh but they're very very slip on
when you're just taking the bins out
that's why i love mine yeah nobody'd
miss you in that fluorescent green pair
would they
very quickly we've got we're running out
of time um tell us mark about the
the rise of the oap dad or parent
actually
well it's it's a lovely story really
which is according to the office for
national
statistics the number of older parents
has
exploded in the last five years i think
something like 1300
um dads in particular over 65 have had
children
and celebrities opting for sleepless
nights uh rather than slippers and uh
a pipe by the fire
thank you both